this is a production of Cornell
University
welcome to the 2023 with hemorina series
my name is limoncerate I'm a second year
PhD student in plant breeding and
genetics and Larry smart slab at corner
University once again accompanied by
Tony Morocco according Alum who has a
systemat in these webinar series and put
it together in all planning and
Logistics
and lastly I just want to mention that
this webinarsity is a compounding of a
larger project which is the development
of educational modules that would be
freely available on the Cornell ham
website at the end of the webinar Series
in each module will have a recorded
webinar an instructional slide Deck with
the teaching style of the subject and a
set of high impact papers pertaining to
the respective subject
all the webinars this one as well as the
future ones and the past ones will be
available on the Cornell sips YouTube
channel if you're interested in
re-watching them or sharing them with
someone that couldn't attend
so without like to introduce our speaker
today's speaker is Dr Nereid Bernstein
she's a senior research scientist head
of the Cannabis physiology Agronomy Lab
at balcony Center in Israel I had the
pleasure to meet her and uh work with
her a little bit at the shs conferences
so
so it's very pleasant to have her here
the topic of her talk today is nutrient
management for optimized production of
secondary metabolizing cannabis I
believe she has to wake her title a
little bit but
so without further Ado please occupancy
take it away
thank you thank you Lewis and welcome
whoever joined us for the webinar today
and I will show you today some of our
results concerning
um nutrient management for candidates
we're looking of course on one hand at
production we want to call it quantity
and on the other hand and quality which
is critically as we know in cannabis
so first of all just to explain why we
need to do all this basic studies basic
work is because since we I mean we know
that cannabis is not a new crop we know
that it's a very ancient crop probably
one among the first crops that Humanity
has been used and we know that it's been
used for medical use and because of this
it has a religions important for the
creation and a lot for commercial values
so it's been used forever and then what
happened what happened and this actually
is important why we need to deal with it
with the research on all type of levels
in the 1961 there was an international
single convection that was signed on the
narcotic drugs and basically at that
time from this minute from 1961 all
research on cannabis stopped so because
cannabis was declared as a narcotic
substance not resistant anymore as a
medical product definitely not allowed
for recreational adults use adults twos
and when we think about it and now it
comes to why this is important to
understand when we think about this
basically the knowledge that we had on
cannabis maybe it was from the 50s but
when we think about cultivation and
Agronomy and plant science in the 50s
compared to what it is today obviously
there is a huge gap so in order to bring
this you know once in order once the
recent changes that Aquarian regulation
and cannabis is gaining in many parts of
the world now a certain level of the of
legal illegal crop either for medical
for recreation or for both or for both
and all of a sudden from this
it has to be the modern cultivation
cultivar either for medical or for
professional use and the level of
knowledge that we had maybe about eight
or nine years ago was almost zero
on this crop
um so therefore there's a need to
develop Innovative agricultivation
Technologies to support the booming
cannabis industry and really I have to
say that when we think of the level of
economic knowledge that we need to have
about cannabis it's a challenge that I
think that we've never faced with any
other cultivar in any other track before
because we're not only dealing with be
able to produce sufficient yield
quantity for The Growers we're not only
dealing with sufficient taste for the
users we're dealing with something that
has to be standardized because it's used
as a medical a medical medical crop and
if not for medical use also for
recreation or for a life quality the
level of the secondary metabolites that
has a biological activity Mitsubishi
standard standardized and this had never
happened before when we compare it to
growing tomatoes or growing ethos I mean
it doesn't really matter if one side of
the tomato is more red than the other
that means that it has more lycopene in
the other because eventually everything
is going to be chopped up into a salad
or into a ketchup it's not been consumed
as medicine and therefore we're coming
from a crop that has very very little or
we had until I mean seven or eight or
nine years ago we had basically no high
agronomic knowledge about into something
that we now have to increase to close
the plant science Agronomy Gap very very
quickly in order to prepare it and
prepare it to be used as a modern crop
so since there there are challenges
challenges there are still challenges
and there are breakthroughs I have to
say that I was because Israel was I
think the first country that legalized
at least medical and the recreational
use following the 1961 convention and I
was approached at that time by the
Ministry of Health and the Ministry of
Agriculture and I was the first
scientist in Israel to be licensed to
work with the crop and then make people
say possibly even in in the world I
don't know but uh at that time there was
so many questions that were coming you
know from growers in Israel growers in
the world and it was difficult to decide
what to work on of course we started
working on nutrition because this is the
fundamental things for growing so what I
just want to say the project in the lab
ever since and today covered in in our
lab cover a large area of research topic
most of them first of all Center is an
optimization of field quantity and
chemical quality
of the of the product
um in terms of working on fertilization
light quality and intensity plant
architecture training and so on
temperature humidity and many other
things so today I will show I'll be
showing data on fertilization everything
Geared for chemical standardization and
optimization of of second of wanted
secondary metabolites
critical issue that you're working on is
prevention of contamination microbial
contamination heavy metal contains to
the compromination pesticide that so
little information is known about
course Harvest practices from the minute
that we cut the cut it what how does the
degradation of the uh of the of the
secondary metabolite and what's the
connection between cultivation practices
and post-harvest qualities
and many other issues also related to
Medical that of course we will not be
covering today so today as Louis said I
was I'm going to talk about optimization
of fertilization
I know fertilizers for increased
secondary metabolite production of
course not neglecting also the quantity
issue of the of the yield so it's plant
development and biomass production
versus or joint with Quality Chemical
quality quantity
so that means that we need to affect
plant performance so how do we affect
plant perform plant performance it's
very basic agronomic question which
tends to be very complicated when we are
hitting cannabis cultivation
but overall we know that environmental
conditions and cultivation conditions
affect plant development and plant
function
so plant development and plant growth
that means that it affects yield
quantity
on the other hand of course
environmental condition and cultivation
conditions also affects not only primary
metabolism in the plant also secondary
metabolism and the yield quantity
build quality of course not quantity
yield quality in cannabis is of course
based on production of the secondary
metabolites and of course there is
interaction between the two because the
secondary primary metabolism and yield
plant development affect very much
secondary metabolism and the quality of
the yield so there are already data
already withdrawal from our labs and
other labs as well which shows that
light effect the secondary metabolism
and temperature and stress conditions
and today we will be focusing on effects
of mineral nutrition
so that if we
briefly mentioned you know secondary
metabolism and hopefully by now I mean
it's very well known it's mostly we have
more than a thousand known biologically
active compounds in cannabis a thousand
it's a huge number and they're divided
into several chemical groups the three
most is the largest one are cannabinoids
which are specific for cannabis or
almost specific for cannabis and then
terpenes and flavonoids which exist also
in other plants and of course because
because we have interactions between
them the interest effect on the
biological activity
whatever agricultural production we will
do if we're thinking about the chemical
quality we cannot ignore compounds other
than it cannot grow at a conference than
cannabis and these of course are
affected by two things so one hand
genetics so different strains a
different potential for production but
this is only the potential whether what
will be produced into what quality is
secondary metabolites will be produced
depending on cultivation condition on
the contribution condition and therefore
the actual production is dependent on
the cultivation condition and
mineral nutrition has a large part of it
so when we started to work on Mineral
nutrition after doing a few studies in
in the greenhouse we decided we have to
go back to what's known for many plants
since maybe the 70s or the 80s so before
that and to know how much nutrients does
the plants take how does the how does
cannabis can respond to nutrient how
much do they need in the first or second
week of cultivation what's the
difference between how the amount that
they need in vegetative stage of
development versus reproductive stage of
development so in order to understand
the plant and to see what the plant is
taking and how does the the amount of
nutrients it is available to the plant
affect the production we had to go into
classical mineral nutrition studies
which are done in
which are done in soilist cultivation so
this will be in Parts in mostly in a
semi-controlled or controlled
environment environmental condition
where everything is regulated how much
if the plant would release the below the
plants what remains in the plant how
much do we have each of those micro and
micronutrients how much do we have in
the living in the flowers and in the
stems and in the root so we can
understand and close the balance and
then know how does the plant will
respond to this so the step most of the
studies that I will show today and let's
tell something else were conducted for
this reason as is very customary for
classical mineral in nutrition studies
that aimed understanding the uptake of
the plant it will be conducted in soils
cultivation in their parts it controlled
in control growing rooms
so one of the first thing that we did is
that this was probably seven years ago
so six years ago is because no one at
the time had an idea but you know what
this plant is doing
so we check this I want to show you we
actually discovered that there's an
issue with standardization the time
before that no one was actually aware of
this so we took a plant and a plant I
mean a very controlled experiment in
which we did several treatments but we
checked concentration in the of the
cannabinoids and terpenoids and
flavonoid the TOEFL plan center the
plant and bottom in the plant maybe
primary inflorescent secondary
fluorescent and tertiary the order in
fluorescence and for I want to show you
some brief just data so if you look at
for example the TLC from the bottom of
the plant Center or the plant and top of
the plant we see obviously that the top
of a planter is much higher
concentration so there is variability
the same thing we can see before CBD the
same thing we can see for CBG and the
opposite trend for CBN this this told us
at the time there is an issue with
standardization and it's very critical
because this is the medication that
patients are taking so if the patients
are taking
12 percent versus six percent it's like
taking one aspirin or two aspirin or two
antibiotics or one antibiotics in one
time so this standardization is critical
because the whatever the consumer is
going to consume is to be obviously
standardized and the big question now
was how does how does environmental
condition combine with this interacts
with this the environment does nutrient
nutrition has
affects this and there is no information
at the time so this is the one of the
initial studies that we did it was done
by a master's student in the lab at the
time so Yakov
and we checked commercial fertilization
versus addition of 20 phosphorus or
addition of npnk together or humic acid
why humic acid because everyone at the
time was saying that humic acid can
improve THC production and CBD
production and great so we thought we'll
try it and what we found out which was
right I mean it was a breakthrough at a
time to see that actually mineral
nutrition have a huge effect on
secondary metabolized production in the
plant for example if we look at
um let's look at what let's look at THC
for example we see the tumetic acid
actually reduced greatly production of
of th of THC addition of LP of npnk
increased production of CBG and CBD was
also reduced reduced by humic acid
meaning let's not discuss whether what
type of fumic acid it is the topic for a
different discussion but what this told
us is there is a huge potential for
mineral nutrition and for for
supplements to affect the secondary
metabolism production
so now we've done the same the same
experiment this is part of the same
experiment by the way the data that I'm
showing you is all published and you can
find it online in most most cases I put
the references
on top that this is of course of public
published data and when we what we did
is now we looked at the same treatments
in the commercial treatment plus
phosphorus plus npka and plasmic acid of
course in addition to the commercial
treatment and we checked in three
different levels on the plant and the
bottom sent flowers from the bottom
center and top of the plants and we so
how is the does it interact with the
nutrition and what we found out and I
just pointed one thing for example if we
look at the humic acid treatment for
Delta 98c what we can see that all of a
sudden the the consideration is
standardized so a different location in
the plant we have similar concentration
this was a huge breakthrough but on the
other hand it was standardized because
it reduced the concentration in the top
and in the center of the plant to a
lower level so that means it doesn't
mean that that's what we want obviously
we want production of The Wanted the
secondary vocabulary that we are
interested to increase but it means that
there's a potential for nutrient
supplementation to affect all also
standardization or development in the
plant
from for now from this point we decided
okay no zero information about response
of the of the plans of cannabis plants
or different nutrients zero information
at a time for how much the plants
actually take up so we started with the
series my I started in the lab a series
of experiments
separately for the vegetative growth of
the plant and separately for the
reproductive growth of course cannabis
is a short Aid plant so under long photo
period it will grow vegetatively and
only when and the resource for the
period there's induction of flower
development in fluorescent development
and the in the reproductive growth so
we've initiated those nutrients for the
first stage the nutrient studies
separately for the vegetative state
growth and for the reproductive growth
and I want to show you some of some of
our results it's right now there's a lot
of data please focus on the image only
and this experiment was a response to
nitrogen Supply this was done by
Aviation a PhD student in the lab Master
student at a time is almost finishing
this PhD student studies now and we
really had no idea where to start with
because there was Zero information so we
started with a very large a range of
nitrogens starting from 30 all the way
to 320 milligram per liter is PPM
and as and we can see so these are the
the five concentrations that we started
as as we can see under 30 PPM is
expected this is a very very low the
plants were small and efficient slightly
better under 80 ppms 160 looked okay so
the 240 320 already suffered from
probably toxicity so we have the
classical response where if the
nutrients going from deficiency to
Optimal range of Supply to over over
threshold of optimum which is towards
the toxicity and if we look at the
development and if we look at the graph
a numerical value of this so we look at
the plant height and biomass production
and so forth it follows the same thing
so this is leafresh biomass and you can
see here the concentration of nitrogen
we could see an increase until an
Optimum and then a decrease same thing
occurs with stem with a fresh oil of the
stem the same thing with fresh weight a
rate of diverse so it's classical
respond and we can we could identify
That 160 PPM nitrogen is an optimal
range
what happened in terms of concentration
you can in terms of consultation in the
plant physiological responses
respiration within dozens of
measurements you can oh I'm not going
obviously to show them you can log into
the publication if you want and see the
plant response a physiological responses
but overall we can see that nitrogen
accumulation is as nitrate in the plant
increased with the increase of Air
Supply so it's a classical plant respond
to a classical parent respond to
nutrients what happened in the
reproductive stage of growth so now
we're talking about the flowering stage
the same type concentration of a night
of nitrogen we can also see deficiency
in 30 and 80 ppms we can also see
beginning of symptoms of unoptimal
conditions under 320 and again the
optimum concentration probably is 100 in
in 60 or so 240 will probably won't have
it but it's not needed so for the sake
of economical condition for the farmers
environmental contamination whether it's
better to stick with hundred and 160 and
we checked it for several varieties but
you know what this is just biomass
production what happened when we
actually went and analyzed constipation
of the therapeutic
the compounds the biologically active
secondary metabolites such as terpenes
and such as cannabinoids actually the
best production was actually the highest
production was actually in those sorry
looking hungry nitrogen starving plants
that's where we received the highest
concentration of the the highest
concentration of those compounds so here
are some examples you can see in many
more of them in our Publications but for
example if we look at cannabinoids and
we look again at the concentration of
the minerals so THC cbga CBD CBC all of
them were highest under their deficiency
conditions and they're decreased with
with increased concentration
same thing for most of the therapies
most of the serpents were highest under
the low concentration of nitrogen and
decreased some of them were some of them
were not were not affected but for many
of them and you can then look at the
publication highest concentration were
in the hardware plant so now now we're
in travel are we going to grow those
tiny hungry looking plants definitely
not we need to find ways and that's what
we're working on to trick the plants to
think that they're under
stress of some kind in order to produce
and this is some of the work that we're
working on in the lab today
so that was nitrogen nitrogen deficiency
best for optimal production
what about potassium this is again was
done by a vesselona so we checked it
again we had no idea where to start so
we had based on knowledge for a chronic
knowledge for a wide range of plants we
checked a concentration from 50 PPM
which obviously was we were hoping to
shoot from deficiency to toxicity from
so we tried concentration from 15 to
2440 a PPM potassium and then we can see
that the 15 in in the 60 plants were at
115 was a the fish and 60 was slightly
longer and then between 100 and 175
there was an Optimum range probably
saying that 100 is sufficient and
there's no rate to increase much a a
pretty much much more than this so this
is for the vegetative phase what
happened at the the reproductive phase
reproductive phase of growth
um
so this is again the same five different
concentration of the potassium of
potassium of potassium by the way I have
to make sure that I explained that the
the irrigation here was done of course
by a fertil fertigulation so that means
that the fertilizer were mixed dissolved
in the irrigation water in the
irrigation water and supplied the plant
is a is mixed and they and also
important to note to note is that most
nutrient studies mineral infusion
studies which are aimed into seeing how
much the plant takes up takes up we use
perlite as the growing substance because
it's a relatively inert pedium so
whatever we give in the irrigation
that's what the plant sees during the
time of irrigation and later on so there
is very little in chemical interaction
with the who is the soulless media and
also we adjust the volume of irrigation
in every irrigation event to make sure
that we have at least 30 between 30 and
35 percent of legit so uh flow flow down
the down the pot but this we ensure that
we don't have accumulation High
accumulation of nutrients in the in the
medium so we Leach the medium and so
that means that it it keeps the
concentration that the root sees whether
rather constant
so going back to potassium so we're
looking at potassium in the reproductive
phase of our Earth again from 15 to 240
um milligram per literus PPM and based
on visual periods and based on a lot of
biomass measurement and physiological
measurements 100 PPM is the optimal
range and it's quite sufficient
sufficient however what happened again
when we measured secondary metabolites
cannabinoids and terpenoids the same
thing happens at the highest
concentration was actually in the
potassium starving plants so both are
potassium eight from nitrogen the best
production of secondary metabolite was
actually in those small looking hungry
hungry plants so now the grower had to
decide is the shooting for higher
concentration higher concentration or is
it shooting for more biomass and of
course another for those for those
Growers which don't sell flowers but
they they actually do extract the way
that they are interested in biomass per
plant or biomass permative Square we
have all this data in the manuscript and
still the same thing occur obviously
that
um I mean there were higher higher
concentration lower and lower this and
for the totals it's possible to look at
the manuscript
um just to show the results again for
for the for the secondary metabolite
production so if we look at the on x
axis on the concentration and the
different cannabinoids so we see again
this is what I was telling you before
the higher conservation of THC and CBD
and cbdva all the most of the
cannabinoids that we tested were highest
under the the fission the military and
deficient plant and it decreased with
the crystal stem and this is again this
is a data for some of the turbines that
we measured and we can see we're going
to be sub for two varieties by the way
so we can see again a reduction highest
concentration for most of them was under
deficiency conditions but not for all of
them for some case some some terpenes
actually increased
um under with increased in conservation
that means that it's not a general
phenomena it's actually a fact on
specific biosynthetic Pathways so it
depending if someone is interested in a
specific turkians or specific
cannabinoids or specific flavonoid the
specific effect of whatever mineral
nutrient or environmental condition in
general will have to be studied just to
show you that those with the responses
the responses are of the plant
responders follow what we see in the
visually and follow the results of the
biomass so for example here if we look
we checked many many physiological
parameters I only show a few of the of
them here so let's for example if we
look at photosynthesis or transpiration
or stomatoconductance these are in two
varieties of two cultivars of cannabis
so we see again the efficiency plant the
product the function is lower then we
have an optimal range of plant function
and again probably a toxicity range a
toxicity range and we say to be on the
safe side probably 100 PPM potassium is
more is the insufficient for cultivation
and the reproductive phase
um
and these are these are the biomass data
for the same experiment that shows that
under low concentration of course
biomass will be lower than under higher
concentration and this is the this is
the results for the fluorescent or the
driveway so this is the this is the
yield
and the yield so we have a contradiction
between the biomass which increases with
increased potassium and with increased
nitrogen and of course the concentration
of cannabinoids and terpenoids it
decreases
philosophers right the big three in
Mineral nutrition is n p and K right so
we looked at nitrogen we looked at
potassium of course we're now going to
look at phosphorus this was a studies
that was done by
chiponi a master's student in the lab at
the time and she was looking at the
phosphorus in the vegetating the growth
phase and the reproductive growth phase
so let's look at the vegetative person
that we show here the results for two
different varieties
and again we started because we have no
idea where to start because there were
no information by the way when I say no
idea it's not because I mean I mean
there's no science-based information if
we were to look at you know on the webs
on the web on the website what we like
to say Dr Google we find thousands of
blogs and many many of them were saying
and still say after today a cannabis is
hungry for phosphorus at the vegetative
growth is the flowering stage you need
to put a shortage you need to put a lot
of phosphorus at the time some blocks
were saying as much as 600 PPM or 1000
PPM now for whoever grows and has an
experience with agriculture you know
that normally the maximum that we do in
soil sculpture in pots is 30. so I
thought I was actually pretty brave by
going on all the way to 90 because most
of our regular crops will die under
these conditions but we said who knows
maybe cannabis is really really unique
you know but going above this you know
it's the way there was no need and we
didn't there to do it so that we did a
classical experiment from 5 PPM until 90
PPM and I was wondering whether we would
get toxicity in spite of you know what
we see by so many cultivators and
Growers that now we know that even use
higher concentration so let's see if
it's needed at least for our type of
studies
what we found out that 5 and 15 was not
sufficient amount of phosphorus but 30
you don't need to go above 30 for the
vegetative growth rates they already
give up step wonderful plant function
optimal cultivation something that we
did find
is that there's a very large range of
optimum range so really from 15 to 90
there were no toxicity symptoms even
above 90. biomass at 15 was pretty on
the good side in order to be on the safe
side we recommend to use 30 a PPM but
definitely there's no need to go above
it and this is this is a graph previous
of the results for biomass for the
plants that we've just seen in the
previous slides so we see the
concentration of phosphorus and we look
at the dry weight into here for two
varieties and we can see the increase
from all the way up to 15 and from 30
all the way up to 90 no chain no
statistical significant change in any of
those two varieties and when we look at
the function of these plants so if we
look for example at the photosynthesis
and transpiration and stomatoconductance
we see the same thing that you know in
maximum increase all the way up to 30
and then in some cases even even
decrease so optimal function and after
30 and really for not because of yield
biomass and not because of plant
function we find in the varieties that
we work with we found no reason to go
above 30.
the interesting thing of course is what
happened at the reproductive and get the
reproductive growth phase
so what happens at the reproductive
growth phase again several varieties
that we did experiment with those two
varieties
and with the with two varieties and we
can see that the same concentration is
low concentration gave the plants were
deficient deficient and but all the way
up to 19 in terms of plant development
and biomass production and yield
production there was no need to go above
30. the optimum again was all the way up
to 90 so we didn't see any toxicity
symptoms or oversupply under 90 but
really there was no reason to go above
30 and what happened when we evaluated
secondary metabolite production the same
thing that we saw for nitrogen and for
potassium also for p also for phosphorus
the highest concentration was in those
deficiency in those hungry plants in the
deficient plants in the in the the
fishing plants so when we look when we
look at the data the biomass so again
what the plants that we've seen a minute
ago we see again an increase in dry
weight
all the way up to up to 30 above 30 the
increase is not a significant is not
significant anymore this is by the way
is total planned biomass this is in
fluorescent biomass each one of those
organ biomass can be is presented
separately and this is the
um the same thing for different
varieties so we think very similar
responses for both for both varieties
what happened about the secondary
metabolites so we presented some of them
they're more in the publication if
you're interested to look in and let's
look for example at the cbda a photo
variety thcd DVA ADH for many men for
most of them highest conservation as I
said before were under in the deficiency
conditions and it reduced with the
increase with increase in
production so it's a grower really it's
difficult definitely we're not going to
grow those hungry plants you know this
because they are small and they produce
small amount of buy of a biome of
biomass
we have to choose somewhere but
increasing above the optimal is
definitely not recommended because
you're risking reducing the secondary
metabolites even even further
in terms of plant function so if we look
at it photosynthesis and transpiration
and stomatoconductance with the
different concentrations so we can see
again classical that in under 30 PPM it
reached the maximum function of a
statistically significant in all of
those plants so there's no real no need
to go way above 30 at least in the
varieties that we've that we've checked
okay so now we thought we know it all
you know we checked in p and K
phosphorus nitrogen and potassium for
all of them biomass was increased until
Center level and secondary metabolite
was highest under deficiency conditions
the lit Murad the massive student in the
lab actually we were just tested last
week and finished a master a master
project very successfully I should say
and this is a paper that's impressed
it's just going to come up probably in a
week or two we published online
a publisher nine and she said she worked
on magnesium in the vegetative and on
the reproductive growth phases and what
we found here again we tried from a very
low concentration all the way to 140
which is quite High quite High
concentration
and we found out that two ppms and 20
ppms were below optimal range but from
35 until 140 this was still an Optimum
brain so we didn't so it's not a
toxicity with the interidentified
obsessity level but we 35 is sufficient
you know to receive optimal
optimal growth and plantive development
in the vegetative stage we can see this
you can see this here tabulated for the
biomass biomass production so this will
this will be the total of the plant and
here we look at the in the leaves and we
could see that
um above 30 we don't get increased in
plant growth okay what happened in the
reproductive stage in the flowering
stage the same five concentration of
magnesium was checked and clearly seeing
deficiency symptoms in the under the low
concentration and then we see an Optimum
concentration all the way up to up to 40
in terms of but this is four yield
quantity right also by the way I want to
say the reason why those branches are
falling down because in order to take a
photograph a nice photograph of them and
put them behind the black screen we have
to remove them from the supporting wires
that we really did and then after
photography whether they're being put in
so that's not the normal way that they
probably just to show the plant
so it's a what we found okay so for here
we say the range is somewhere between 20
to 140 in terms of biomass yield in
terms of yield production in terms of
quantity
what happened in terms of quality so we
were kind of sure NPK gave us deficiency
the best concentration let's see what
happened here they know what this is now
what happened for magnesium magnesium is
very different it's very different if we
look at the concentration of magnesium
increasing concentration of magnesium on
the x-axis and we look here I put an
example of some cannabinoids under the
fish magnesium deficiency we receive the
very low concentration of cannabinoids
and they actually increase and we
receive an Optimum concentration
under 35 PPM and only above 35 PPM for
some but for most cannabinoids we
receive no statistical difference for
some of them there was a slight
difference so again from the varieties
that we took that we evaluated there's
no reason to go above 35 but you need 35
in order to make sure that you don't
hurt your production by the way it's um
the physiology of why each one of those
cannot if which minerals are affecting
differently is fascinating in terms of
magnesium mechanism for example is
critical for ATP function and for a
function of more than 300 enzymes in the
plant and it's important for sugar
loading into the flow and therefore
translocation of sugars and the
carbohydrates to the flower and it's
critical for many many other other
processes it's a part of the chlorophyll
chlorophyll molecule and it's important
for for the system for for the state for
activity of rubisco for uh for for
photosynthesis so the responses are not
just respondents for stress it's not
like we have nitrogen deficiency of
whatever deficiency that by why the
plant increased and because the
responses for each one of those
nutrients is can be broken down to
physiological factors that the plants or
that the plants are involved with the
the minerals are involved with
a involvement
um okay in terms of nutrient that's the
probably almost the last the last groups
they want to quickly show and this is a
work that was done again by Avia during
his PhD studies for nitrogen there are
two major forms of nitrogen that the
plant can take up and they're very
different one of them is ammonium which
is NO3 minus so it's an anion the other
one is um so nitrate which is NO3 minus
and then ammonium which is no4 plus so
it's an anion and a cation and it
affects very much physiology of the
plant or even up to the level of pH of
the cytoplasm and many other
compounds and many other processes in
the plants so it's always a question
okay we know how much nitrogen to be
what ratio of ammonia to nitrate should
we give so we tested this and if this is
an experiment we gave either 100 so this
is the percentage of ammonium
among all the nitrogen that was given so
we either gave it as a hundred percent
nitrate or 100 ammonia or ratios with
name so this is in terms of percentage
of ammonium it's 0 10 30 50 and 100
percent
from all the nitrogen that we gave the
plants and the this again is also of
course published and what we can see
even just by looking at the plant 100
PPM ammonium the plant did not survive
so all the plants died
zero percent ammonia atom meaning 100
nitrate the plants were really happy and
we were looking at the biomass it's easy
to see to see this on the biomass we see
that the highest plant
um the best morphology the highest plant
growth and development actually occurred
under zero percent ammonia 100 nitrogen
nutrition which is what cannabis prefers
how does it affect cannabinoids so the
same thing we saw the highest production
of cannabinoids and there's zero percent
um of some cannabinoids under zero
percent the ammonia so 100 nitrate for
some of them for some of the Cannabis
that the differences were not statistics
statistical so probably we can we are
safe to go all the way up to 30 percent
um ammonium if needed but probably zero
percent ammonium is is better for uh for
cannabis
the last slide that I want to show that
they that I want to show today for the
nutrients is a this ways
um
sorry this with
the way that we calculate the way that
we need to calculate how much mineral to
give the plant in every stage of growth
the studies that I showed now were we
have to start with somewhere so we have
to find out what's the response of the
plant to different levels of those
minerals and by the way we have
conducted experiments in the lab in
other nutrient as well and zinc and
manganese and many other and others that
that we are in a process of standing in
the map for publication but something
but this was a good steady concentration
throughout the cultivation throughout
the vegetative or throughout the
reproductive phase other than doing
flashing in the end which means reducing
level of concentration at the last
um we can have approach
but still there's another level many
levels of layering that need to be that
need to be investigated in order to
understand plant response for example
that um should we give different
concentration every week this depends on
how much of the plants actually takes up
every week at the beginning the plants
are smaller definitely they take up less
than with their larger and also their
phonological differences that different
stages of development the plant might
need more or less more or less so how do
we deal with this the in agriculture we
usually try to develop What's called the
position rate curves what is the
position rate is how much nitrogen is
being deposited into the plant in the
first week of cultivation second week of
conclusion third week of conclusion and
so on how much copper how much
molybdenum how much iron how much
posters and so on so we're working on
this and this is a again this is
publication that will come occurs soon
and we're looking in this race it's time
after planting so unlike the previous
River looking at age it age of the plant
the first group of Curves is for the
vegetative stage of growth and this is
for the flowering stage of growth so we
cut the plants many many times
destructively and analyze how much
minerals in the leaves and the shoots
and Earth so we can know how much the
plant takes up every week and what
because this so this is just gram per
plant so we could see that of course as
the plant grows there's an increase in
the amount of nutrients now if we take
the the diff the difference the the
difference integral between one point
and the other this will give us the
deposition rate curve which means how
much goes into the plant in the first
week and the second week in the third
week and so on it's too complicated and
there's no time to clearly show it here
but just what I want to show you that
there are differences between nutrients
for example if we look at nitrogen all
the way up to the end of population the
plant keep on taking educated a nitrogen
and phosphorus and in iron and potassium
but if we look at calcium
no they stop taking calcium much more
early early so for example and this was
done by the way for between three and
five cultivars so we know this is it
tells us for example that probably
during this stage of growth there's no
morning to fertilize with calcium and it
also tells us how much to give at every
stages of growth so this is the next
level I think that we need to deal with
what else do we do in the lab and I'm
not going to show this obviously we're
dealing with nutrition I just thought
that you may want to be interested or
interested to look at some of our
publication we're dealing with light
quality Spectrum effect on plant growth
but light intensity temperature effect
studies about flowering control a lot of
work about post-harvest chemical changes
to see what happened post-harvest and
how can I how can we affect post-harvest
by cultivation because sometimes
cultivation cultivation affect both and
nutrition as well affect post Harvest
effects of Botanical and conventional
Pest Management treatments because we
have to deal with contamination and many
other
issues like okay
um okay we also do a lot of work on
plant architecture so and this is for
standardization if we look at the plant
we analyzed concentration at primary and
secondary influences so this is these
are the callers so to speak with more
inherent fluorescence which have more
shading and we analyze the difference
between microclimates in the plant and
stabilization and conservation we did
this and made on more than four
varieties it's published in two or three
Publications this is control plans
plants that would be only the
defoliation only removing the leaf
removing leaves and branches from the
bottom of a plant already removing
secondary branches and so on one frame
or two trim branching and two pinching
to the plant and of course you know all
of this in order to see the effect on
standardization and on deal and on the
yield quantity we also checked and this
was done by in the deaf dancing girl it
was a master's student in a lab at a
time and also the same type of plant
pruning how do are they affected by
plant density because plant density is
very important whether you plant one
plant per meter two plants per meter 10
plants per meter per course it's the
matter of plant the interaction between
plant architecture and plant the density
to summarize I want to say that
first of all we found out that we know
that mineral nutrition and I showed
today NPK and magnesium has the
considerable impact on secondary
metabolism in cannabis so there's a
power and there's
a problem there's a potential for those
in order to control secondary metabolism
we have to be careful with this second
thing is the field quantity and chemical
quality are very often affected
definitely by mineral nutrition
and therefore there is an urgent need
for science by implant science
information for sand based plant science
information to support the developing
cannabis industry and plant science is
important you know it's the basic for
everything for nutrition for any
economical process
and so there are many challenges and
there are also breakthroughs definitely
further we need further development of
our Technologies for the Improvement of
cultivation both for quantity and for
quality
development of Advanced Technologies for
directing the chemical quality so not
only the quantity and controlling the
the clinical quality is a major issue
for specific chemical indications so
once we will know what secondary
metabolites are required for whatever
indication it's not only a need to
identify which strain which cultivar
works on whatever medical indication it
also will be a need how to make sure
that it produces the same profile
consistently within and between batches
of growth and I want to thank my amazing
lab Group which is it keeps changing
throughout the years many of them don't
want to live in doing Masters and PhD
and whatever
it's a very very difficult studying
medical cannabis is really difficult
because of the regulation we spend a lot
of our time under cameras and other
emotions and detectors and whatever and
it's very dedicated group that was
facilitated in order the accumulation of
the information that we were able to do
the funding for the studies that they
show you comes from the chief scientist
fund of the Ministry of Agriculture in
Israel because in 1916 cannabis was
declared as a crop Elite a crop in
Israel which is a legal definition it
means that we are allowed to apply for
funding to study this plan and in the
beginning some of the plant material
that we use came up from three growers
in Israel from Kendo which is we still
collaborate with a lot with from Bol
Pharma and from El fonteva deal in the
in the past and the some of the we're
working together with Dr Molly Zacks
from the extension service in Israel on
the composition of the nutrient solution
which is not an easy thing to do in
order to maintain such very good level
of stability between the treatment and
that's it thank you
thank you so much Dr Brunson uh you have
some several questions and I'm sure
there will be more as we are talking
right now
so we would like for me to read the
question so you want to access them
yourself
um I can access them myself okay
have you seen any modification
it's only immediatives right I have to
read them out loud the questions right
yes I hope to show you if you can read
them out loud yes
have you seen
you've seen sex they
asked the good questions we were very
concerned about this because we were
expecting that maybe under stress
conditions we will see sex change the
answer is no we didn't but we did see
under stress if something went wrong
with the irrigation system and the
plantain University of irrigation
obviously that we had the male
development but not under stress with
nutrient with nutrient in none of our
experiments
another question is could it be that the
lower nitrogen level had the higher
concentration because there was less
biomass
a meaning the same quantity of THC but
less biomass meaning higher
concentrations so this is a really good
question when we deal with nutrition and
concentration of an element we already
we many times think about what we call a
dilution effect which is what was it was
described here by the person that asked
it so maybe it's the same amount that's
being produced just higher because it's
under
um because it's in less biomass so the
answer is that we don't think so and
because I there is no time to go into
too deep into metabolomics what we've
done for the nitrogen studies we also
done metabolomics primary metabolomics
that the study will probably come up
really soon and what we know that's
happening is that our hypothesis was
that under a high when there is enough
nitrogen what is the plant produced it
throws it into proteins DNA or so on and
growth right so either if there's enough
nitrogen there's enough growth in
primary metabolism but there's not
enough nitrogen we still get some
photosynthesis we still have energy but
not enough in order to build High
nitrogen compounds and that's when the
plant there's a metabolic shift that was
our hypothesis and it's worked out to be
this is the case that there's a
metabolic shift toward production of
compounds that don't contain nitrogen
such as
cannabinoids so we believe that under
nitrogen the what we're seeing we are
seeing a metabolic shift under two level
we call them C metabolites metabolizes
don't contain nitrogen because there's
not enough nitrogen to support growth
the um production of proteins and or
amino acids and or nitrogen DNA and RNA
and so on
um okay another question is does NPK
affect a male and okay this was already
ask whether we can use this for
breathing so this is I answer this
another question is did did you estimate
total secondary metabolite production
per plant with the nutrient deficiency
studies for example the deficient plants
at higher concentration but due to
biomass reduction or total secondary
metabolize production lower okay so we
checked this and it's oh it's available
in the publication you can take a look
at it because we also thought maybe it
can be for people who are doing
extraction maybe this can be can work
out you know if we get low biomass but
huge amount of concentration it still
may be that for extraction if we use if
you get more biomass with lower with
lower concentration maybe the number the
the amount the weight of the secondary
metabolites will stay the same so this
was not the case and I mean it was not
the case so when there is a reduction
there is a reduction for overall plant
and you could see the the calculations
in our manuscript
okay another question this is probably
an ignorant question there's no ignorant
questions
um it's a lot in plant science but I
don't understand why the concentration
of a nutrients should be
transcends in comparison in comparing
impact of cultivation strategy was
transient
I don't know what it is the
concentration would be an external water
supplied but not absorbed in totally by
the plant what about total amount of
water absorbed size of the plant rate of
transpiration and all the other
variables I would think this is like
talking about
the relative impact of seeding a child
or feeding a child porridge made of 50
oats and 50 water rather than 60 40.
wouldn't the key thing be the quantity
of Oats actually actually absorbed not
to mention frequency of feeding okay
I'll explain the question I think it's a
wonderful question the person actually
deals if we put it in agronomic terms
tells about an interaction between
irrigation and fertilization if we give
because I what we were talking about I
was talking about in this
in the webinar today I was talking about
concentration that we give in the plants
so let's give same volume with same
concentration and I also said that we
make sure that we have 30 of widgets so
we stay we stay relatively similar
concentration but what the question was
and it's a matter of also of how much we
give because if we give one liter with
bio concentration with certain
concentration over give two liters with
same consideration or if you give three
liters we say concentration the total
amount of nutrients that we gave the
plant differs so this is a good question
the reason why it's not an issue in our
study is because is because we're using
that's why in Mineral nutrition studies
we usually we try to use inert
soil inert media growing media so we're
using perlite and we have 30 of leeches
that means that even if we take now and
give two liters what will happen the the
amount of water that will stay in the
container is the maximum amount of water
that the container can hold and the rest
of it will Leach down
we Leach down so once we monitor the
cons the volume that glitch down and how
much we give and keep it steady that
means that the plant received equal
amounts based similar the plant is
exposed to equal amount and in addition
to
to equal to equal concentrations
so I hope this was clear if not please
ask again
um
okay another question was
um do a
is there a textbook that would capture
much or all of this information
I'm asked this question very much how
come that you haven't published a book
yet about minerals vision of plants you
know it's very tempting when we only had
nitrogen and potassium was saying well
maybe it's time no now there's still
many many ways to go I think that there
is
a need really I think there's a need for
a cannabis textbook I think it's going
to be very challenging because from the
time that the text Will begin to be
written until it's been closed probably
the amount of information will double
because people are just now starting to
work to work intensively on it and I
fully agree that there is a need you
know for Tech textbook on cannabis we're
thinking about it other people are
thinking about it as well but we are not
there you know there
can you discuss the concentration of
nutrients you have reviewed in relation
in relationship with each other for
example the amount of n versus p in
various stages of plant development this
is a really good really good question
a very important issue in Plant
Nutrition is not only the absolute
amount that we give the plant but also
the ratio between nutrients so and this
comes from many so many reasons one of
them is that there's interaction between
nutrients for optic into the plants so
if for example we have in a soil
solution in a root solution we have
higher conservation of
calcium which we worked on and it will
publish this soon it it will reduce
uptake of
other cations such as magnesium and
potassium for example so this is one
reason another thing that could be
interaction in the plant as well there's
a big competition for applicant of the
plant competition for
um translocation from the root of the
shoot and specific physiological
interaction
so as I said there's the even though we
are investigating this issue for several
years very intensively very intensively
this is first this is the first stage
and because from my point of view I mean
my point of view we we have to start
somewhere and because there is
absolutely zero information we my choice
the way my choice to do it is to start
working on each nutrient separately
giving the next the other nutrient in
the optimum concentration so after we
finish for example the nitrogen
concentration for potassium we already
optimized or in this experiment based on
what we know of course there is
interaction with you between nutrients
there's been a one a one or two studies
that came up for cannabis that started
to deal with interaction between
nutrients
um between nutrients so different
researchers may have different point of
view in my opinion is that only now acid
I know what's the range was the optimal
range deficiency or toxicity range now
within this optimal range we need to
optimize for relate for ratios between
nutrients
before we actually know roughly where
the optimum rates is it's going to be
almost impossible to have a grid of 300
to 400 treatments in order to do it it's
possible but it also forces reduction in
repetitions in the per treatment and so
on so what I think is that there are
several stages first stage for my very
important stage for my point of views is
to up to evaluate effects for a range of
concentrations
the different issue is then is to
evaluate for a range of ratios between
nutrients between different nutrients
and of course to evaluate effects on
different duration of growth so this is
I mean trying to close the research gap
of 30 years it's 30 30 or 40 years it's
very it's we are heading in this
direction and we're working as fast as
possible as well as other groups and
definitely it's important
but I also want to say one last sentence
is that because we've analyzed I mean in
all of our
um studies we invested
a huge amount of effort in funding with
mineral nutrition is really expensive we
didn't analyze only potassium in our
potassium experiment we analyzed almost
all micro and micronutrients several
times during the growth period in
separating the roots and the leaves and
the stems and the flowers and the flower
the flower leaves and the sugar leaves
the flower leaves so we have for example
we when we look at a different
concentration of
magnesium for example we can see how it
affected calcium so it gives us an
indication of what ranges of magnesium
calcium will be affected and what ranges
of nitrogen phosphorus may be affected
and now based on this information which
was enormously difficult and expensive
to and time consuming to accumulate it
will be it will make us easier to direct
and experimented with study relationship
between a different ratios between
different minerals
can you extend on the effects of luxury
feeding of phosphorus in the flowering
stage
um
we know that many of the Growers believe
I mean it's a belief that if you use a
high conservation of phosphorus luxury
feeding
luxury filling is giving more phosphorus
we also use luxury consumption which is
more important that means that not
always but there is a lot in the root
Zone it will mean that the plant will
take up a lot sometimes there's a lot
higher concentration in the real Zone
and the plant will not take it up then
it's less deported but in phosphorus we
see also luxury consumption we saw it
also for potassium it's very well known
for potassium meaning if we gave more
higher concentration in the root Zone we
had higher luxury consumption into the
plant and higher concentration in the
plant so many Growers believe and will
give very large consultations of
phosphorus during the flowering stage
because they believe they did affect
so-called bud I mean it's not a bad
fluorescent is not a bad but it's
something else totally botanist or even
hesitating to say the word but they
believe that it will give a more denser
and larger fluorescence and from our
experiments yes and it's in the
publication also we do see that the
flowers the flowers themselves not in
fluorescent the flowers themselves tend
to have to be larger but when you but
when we measure overall biomass of the
of the yield of the fluorescence it
doesn't change and also when we change
cannabinoids they decrease entrepreneur
is
the open loads decrease so
um so everyone needs to do their own
their only calculations of what they're
interested to grow but in terms of but
in terms of yield weight it doesn't help
in terms of yield quantity I mean
conservation of cannabinoids
entrepreneurs it definitely damages so
it may end up being and also one thing
that's important the fact that it looks
more denser when it's fresh doesn't mean
that it's going to be this way when the
tissue dries out you know the way the
the way that we try and make sure
cannabis
how many days after planting in the
reposition rate curve study where the
plants switched to reproduction cycle
okay so what we did is that in order to
make sure that we get a good enough
description of what happened in the
vegetative rate of growth we actually
did it in two batches meaning we grew
the plants in the vegetative stage
longer than what we normally would I
can't remember offhand I think it was 40
days or 45 days something like this or
30 days but and then of course in in
parallel we had another group of plant
that was switched to the reproductive
stage as customary with the cultivation
so we drag the vegetative stage a little
bit longer in order to
see that we get a good description of
the vegetative development thanks
okay why do you think nnp deprived plans
produced more desirable compounds so for
nitrogen I already answered this I said
that we believe that there is a our
hypothesis was that there is a metabolic
shift toward production of low nitrogen
producing
compounds such as cannabinoids in
metabolic studies in primary and
secondary metabolomic studies this was
we've shown this to be true it's a paper
that we are just submitting for
publication this week
and for phosphorus
um we can only guess I mean we know that
phosphorus is part of ATP so it's part
of the energy budgets of the plants it's
part of anything really so we don't
right right now we don't have any
working
um experiment in order to work on
phosphorus because we're we've because
we are dealing with many other nutrient
symptoms of metabolomics right now but
it it can basically be very much big
because you know phosphorus is involved
in so many and so many enzymatic
reactions and in energy utilization in
the plant that you just shut down a
activity Maybe
so because it I mean instinctively it
makes sense it says if there's a
reduction in biomass that means that the
reduction in energy there's a reduction
in production of secondary metabolites
it sounds it sounds logical here we
received an increase in an increase so
we say it's possible it really will mean
that um that maybe some kind of
production is
um is inhibited and the deficiency more
than other type of metabolic production
which may may be causing this so maybe
the downstream metabolic processes are
inhibited because of phosphorus
efficiency which allows arimetabolic
processes to continue toward the
production of terpenoid and cannabinoids
which share of course A Part A partly a
similar metabolic process processes and
it's a good question let's say and I
also have to say that I'm so happy that
we've reached the stage in which we can
even think about it because now we know
that this is the case you know about the
two years ago three years ago we had no
idea at least now we know what the
phenomena is and it's time to start time
to start working on the on the mechanism
for why this is happening
and another question is is research of
elements showed in this presentation
done on clones meaning cuttings or from
seeds if from seeds was seed from seed
difference they affected and differently
affected the results between the plants
okay great question
um first of all the study was done with
clones and it was done with cloned from
similar from same other plants so
because the lab in order to get the
differences that we were able to get the
very small variation between treatments
and between treatments we are we're
freaks for uniformity of cultivation
conditions I mean people often ask us
how come you know your standard errors
is so small some of the divisions are so
small for biomass and for height and for
cannabinoids and maybe this is because
we invest a huge amount of energy and
thought and effort into making sure that
our our
replicates are are similar and it's gone
through the fact that for example we
start from clones obviously if we start
from seeds probably a lot of the trends
that we'll see we won't be able to see
because of variability so we start from
clones with simple same mother plants we
start with probably about half more
clothes than we need with than we need
to so we I mean we generate probably
like twice as many clones as we need so
at the beginning of the experiment we
can we can store them for uniformity of
morphology and size so they're very
uniform when they go into the experiment
they don't even have one centimeter
difference between them when they start
so this allows us and in the cultivation
room
every week we go with my light meter but
we try to ever to eradicate every
variability that has a large effect on
the planet's light obviously is one of
them so the students the student goes in
the in the in the growing room and every
week measure light intensity in every 20
centimeters 20 centimeters I think is
maybe 15 inches 10 inches I forgot on
the grid and adjusting the light light
intensity of the reflectors or whatever
needed to me to make sure that we have
absolutely uniform conditions so this is
why we are able to get very low
variability between replicator this
wouldn't have been possible with seeds
not with the level of uniformity of lack
of uniformity in in genetic material
from seeds as we have today
okay we're looking at individual
nutrients how did you supply the other
necessary minerals for normal growth
and this is very good question a major
question in Mineral nutrition we have a
problem in in science or we're probably
in the world it's impossible to take
magnesium just to add it into the
solution
by itself meaning if we have a solution
that's made up from not 20 you cannot
break the salt and egg so you have to
edit it is this magnesium sulfate
magnesium nitrate magnesium chloride
whatever and so it's difficult so what
we do we don't start with a uniform
growing conditions we have we make
before we start we actually
um we have rested we build recipes that
that make that make sure that we keep as
much as possible all other nutrients
uniform and change only the nutrients
that we that we need in terms of
magnesium for example it was possible to
do it for for we will be able to keep
all nutrients constant because of
playing with different salts all the way
up to the fourth treatment for the fifth
treatment
we have we had to select another ion
that will increase and now the question
is what iron do you select and it's a
major issue in Mineral nutrition in
magnesium for example at the fifth
treatment there was 140 PPM all the way
uh only at the last treatment we had to
add an ni and a different anion and we
selected to do it with sulfate
um with sulfate because sulfur we've
checked in previous experiment it
doesn't accumulate to higher
concentration in the plant within this
within this range so all of the
treatment treatment one to four received
if I remember correctly 83 I think 80
maybe 85 I forgot exactly PPM and in the
highest mechanism treatment it was it
was a bit higher it was around a it was
around 120 or 130. this still is within
the range of reasonable sulfate
concentration for them
for the plant and also we know from
prior experiment that it doesn't have an
effect it's a great question and it's
something that we deal with nutrients
with mineral nutrition all the time and
we do the best that's why we don't use
fertilizers we use salt actually lab
salt to mix individually each one of
those treatments and we built it the
best we can to make sure that we have we
don't deviate from that's not really
that we keep as much as possible
constant concentration of all other
nutrients
did you notice in CBD cpg plants
the training fertilizer at the optimal
point would increase the THC content
over 0.3 percent and first phosphorus in
particular could cause this
um well the varieties that we use and
most of them I mean we for some of the
studies we use the high THC variety a
high CBD variety and a balanced have 360
varieties most of them but we have most
of them were not done with only a high
THC variety because of the large
interest that we have in in Israel and
in Israel we don't have the 0.3
restriction because all our cultivation
has to be done in greenhouses and indoor
nothing is in the is in nothing is in
the field we're not allowed to grow
because of
scares the worries about contamination
from the soil it all has to be soilless
cultivation and you know greenhouses or
um
growth Chambers or indoor so I don't
have a very good answer about CBD only
variety they don't have a THC but from
the varieties that we have from the
balanced varieties and from throughout
the experiment that we have we noticed
that I mean the at least for the effect
on the on phosphorus
um
the highest concentration we received
under phosphorus deficiency so this was
true for CBD concentration for THC
concentration for CBG concentration for
all of them so actually the highest
concentration were under deficiency and
the more we increase phosphorus all
those the concentration of all this
reduced so now we didn't find an
increase with the in THC
with a with an increase in phosphorus
the opposite was actually true
could Growers Implement a targeted npt
restriction near the end of the
reproductive phase to achieve similar
levels of increased secondary metabolite
concentration or does the nutrient
stress need to happen over the entire
lifespan
great questions we are dealing with
flashing right
um just to tell you that we're actually
finished writing a manuscript about
clashing we didn't have time to load it
again
um for whoever is maybe not
we're not familiar with this most
Growers and most Growers at the last
week or week and a half 10 days a week
of cultivation some use different
durations they either completely stop
giving fertilizers so they give just
water or reduce some of the fertilizer
this is called term flashing in the
Cannabis the jargon
and the the question is here can we
um it's very logical it says can we just
give nutrients
whatever we need but just do flushing at
the end and this will replace the need
for to give deficiency conservation so
first of all I'll have to say that all
our studies were done with flushing I
mean many of them we've done because we
didn't we asked ourselves the same
question we did actually grew double the
amount of plants and we did half of them
with flash and half of them if we didn't
Flash and the the those that the
flashing versus non-flashing will come
up in a different experiment in a
different study in other words no it
doesn't help and the reason is that
um the reason is that the production of
secondary metabolite doesn't start at
the last week of motivation it's a
process you know throughout several
weeks before it so probably this is what
they're affecting and also it's a
probably a matter of overall energy
balance and availability in the plant so
but this is again these are all issues
of well I mean not necessarily during
the last week of flashing but can we
give it at the last half of a
cultivation can we give it the center of
the cultivation all this is questions
that need to be worked out and these are
definitely questions that we will need
to to work about is very important to
work about them
what are the best journals for getting
primary literature on cannabis
cultivation
um
well
um if the question is about
scientific journals and I'm going to ask
answer with scientific journal then
um I think that they
I think that the
publication scientific publication about
cannabis have been published in many
journals I mean in many journals there
are two journals which are specific for
cannabis or actually three the third one
that was initiated but not necessarily
these studies will be will be done there
and we see the Cannabis cultivation
anywhere you know I don't even want to
name names of Journal because really it
can be found anywhere the question is
are they available to the public or not
some of those will be open access
meaning that you can just punch in and
download the PDF with them and some of
them will be accessed only through
libraries or through paying directly to
the publisher so the best way is not to
search to my opinion not to search
specific journals but what we do in
science is to search
keywords I mean if if someone doesn't
have access to Scientific databases then
just use Google and write cannabis
nitrogen cannabis phosphorus cannabis
nutrition so on and this will Direct in
addition to the
non-scientific or looking Google Scholar
then it will direct to Scientific
publication that dealing with this
whatever issues of power of Interest
are you doing any CO2 enrichment studies
under enhanced CO2 would you expect
greater nutrient demand
yeah okay that's a good that's a great
question
um we didn't do any CO2 enhancement
studies
um
there are several reasons to them one of
them we're trying to mimic also
Greenhouse cultivation but all our rooms
have very good I mean a very good
ventilation so we are working under an
ambient CO2 it never goes below so it's
CO2 but it doesn't never goes below
ambient CO2 concentrations so our in
other words consideration are in our
growing room are identical to the
conservation
which are outside because of the way
that the replacement of air circulation
in the in the in the grow in the growing
rooms
and is it going to affect to affect
mineral uptake if it's the I think the
answer is that if it's going to affect
growth rate then it's going to affect
mineral uptake because minerals are
needed for growth if we need more leaves
to be produced and we need more nitrogen
for protein we need more calcium for
cell wall for example this is very
simplistic so if there will be more
growth there'll be more need for for
nutrients for nutrients on top of this
it may have
um seal enriched CO2 enrichment of
course may have an effect on specific
on the specific processes the metabolic
or others in the plant which made
theoretically affect need for for
nutrients and then potentially mineral
mineral uptake this is when working on
of course CO2 will affect photosynthesis
which will affect
energy I mean carbohydrate the same
coat of fixation and carbohydrate
availability all this can have an effect
but whether it goes above above
affecting specific growth processes it's
something that needs to be investigated
do you expect the result that Louis you
if we are over time and you need to stop
us then stop us okay uh I have no
problem like I have the freedom of
extending this as long as I can as long
as we get to all the questions
okay
okay do we expect the results uh do we
expect the result to be consistent
across different growing media
um okay the question is what is the
result I mean the result that we were
shooting for that we were receiving is
the effect of different concentration in
the root Zone on plant function
because the way that those nutrients
were done is with the media that's as
soilless as a inert as possible enough
leaching so we don't build up
concentration of the plant so which
allows us to really focus on the
response of the plant to a steady
concentration to a uniform concentration
in the nutrient solution now what happen
if we use different growing media so we
know of course many of the exactly in is
in Israel a growing number of
um cultivators is using paralyte but
most cultivators of course is using
media rich with the organic organic
media the main difference will be one of
the differences will be that the
nutrients will be sold to the to the
media so if the media is less inert then
we have absorption and desorption of the
of the nutrient they can build up to
higher the concentration that means in
one hand that we will need to supply
more to overcome whatever is remained in
the roots in the media is soaked to the
media and on the other hand there's a
possibility for the media to release to
release so the way to do it and this is
the same as asking when we grow tomatoes
in heavy soils or in sandy soil will the
response be different the plant itself
enlarge is going to behave similarly
other than the fact that the media can
affect the root development and
morphology and so on but the plant
itself is going to respond differently
we just need to account for different
interactions with the with the media
itself
but the first thing is that to
understand what the plant need what the
plant takes up every week well how does
it respond when we Supply a distant
depth concentration and then we need and
after having this understanding then it
needs to be adjusted to different
growing Media or different soils for
other other
for other crops
another question have you ever analyzed
bedroom cam products do you think if
they are really standardized since that
is their marketing page and we all know
that in Canada they were not
standardized thank you I have never
analyzed products I don't know okay
um are you a paper open source
um
I try my best I mean let's say that if
I'm a researcher at volcanic Center over
30 30 years now and before cannabis I
mean this the criteria for selection of
journals might have been different but
with cannabis we I feel kind of a public
responsibility because I know that so
many people are interested in those data
that I do my best to publish them open
access and most large really large
percentage of those Publications are
published in a open access to a journals
several of them are not and I always
tell people that if they come across
something that it's not available to
them please feel free to contact us and
we'll be able happy to share those
Publications but I think that about 80
of our publication we pay huge sum for
Open Access or actually some of the
journals many of them contact us they
really want to publish those
Publications so we get them open access
for free depending because we know that
there is a huge interest in the
publication it's a you sometimes amazed
by you know with those journals
published in them and we look at the
paper a day later two day later it's a
routine thousands of people that
downloaded them and looked at them so we
know that it's important to let people
have access to those to help to have
access to those journals also to people
that don't have access to Scientific
Library
are there any plans to perform
deficiency studies based on Leaf tissue
testing
to account for Growers who are not
growing in in Earth media
wow that's a
okay I'm telling you all my secrets
that's okay I have to tell you that in
all of the study the question for those
just to explain this how important this
question is the question is really
asking about um
evaluating what the plan what the
nutrition status of the plant based on
analyzing
Leaf concentrations
um
uh so we call this an Agronomy we call
this representatively what does that
mean that we identify on a clientele it
can be a basal plant a tomato plant
pepper plant we identify what's called a
representative lead at least that in
every stage in the in a growing cycle we
can go to it and Sample it and we know
what consideration to expect if the
plant is under optimal condition so
developing those tables of
Representative leaves are a great way of
assisting a existing Growers that want
to know what their situation is is to
create those tables that says in this
stage of growth this is what you expect
in the leaves nitrogen potassium sodium
in the flowering stage this is what you
expect in the living water so so
developing concentration in the in the
representatively is very critical what I
want to tell you that in all of the
experiments we conducted in the lab all
of the experiments in addition to
analyzing
conservation and leave root shoot we
also sampled representative leaves from
hundreds thousands of samples and now
after we finish this actually all the
students the those that left the lab I
didn't left the lab got together the
last couple months and last two months
we finished analyzing all the leaves and
actually we were in the final process of
putting those tables together and they
will be published uh published soon so
it will give us you know what actually
we are generating with this is that for
every it will be separate for the
vegetative stage it's separate for the
reproductive stage and based on the five
concentration of nitrogen we know under
Optimum condition what it should be and
we this will be the first step into
generating those concentration
um optimal concentration for a
cultivation
and I think that other people are
working on this as well it's very
important
okay have you investigated the
accumulation of heavy metals and in
fluorescence
gosh every one of those questions I have
to say yes it's in the process so I have
to tell you that this is a issue that's
a major concern because a major concern
because cannabis is considered to be a
If plants that we can be used for
bioremediation meaning some plants can
take up they have a tendency to take up
high concentration of heavy metals and
other contaminants as well and to
survive it well up to the point that
it's considered to be used even for
cleaning soils through cleaning soil and
hemp is considered to be a plant that's
good for heavy remediation this is one
of the reasons by the way that you know
when we're thinking about contamination
that in Israel we only allowed to
cultivate the Cannabis under soilist
cultivation and we have to test we have
it by by law we have to test the
conservation of everything
microbials heavy metals a huge number of
chemicals in the soil before we even
plant we plant the plants this is by by
law but so we were concerned about it
because normally in those soilist media
is being used there's not that many
heavy metals but even you know some of
our micronutrients such as zinc and
copper and iron they're heavy metals you
know so we were considering what happens
you know do they accumulate only in the
root do they are they in the stem are
they in the leaves do they accumulate in
the fluorescence and actually it's a
vehicle a master student in the lab is
working on this issue we did two things
we just completed I'm telling you all
the secrets again we just it's not so
good so we just completed the a study in
which we gave the plant different mixes
of different heavy metals and we are
analyzing to see how much of it actually
arrives into the fluorescence
one thing that I can already say and
this is not from this experiment this is
from data that you can look in our
Publications if you look at our
publication we because we analyzed
micronutrients in all of this so we
could we can see where in the plant are
zinc and manganese and copper and iron
accumulate and what we can see that many
of those heavy metals luckily we retain
in high concentrations in The Roots so
they they do move to the in fluorescence
but under we see higher accumulation in
the position in the roots and sometimes
lower the route to shoot the
translocation whether this is true also
under highly specifically High
concentration of heavy metals this
remains to be seen
um okay the last question is I know the
temp can control weeds
effectively do you think it would be
appropriate to use it as a cover crop
um
I I don't know it's a I don't have an
experience with him cultivated in the in
the field you know a very little
experiment with self-cultivated in soil
and I have no idea it will also be an
issue I think legal issue of
whether or not but I really don't know
I think that was the last question that
was the last question I can just say
quickly that there are some Mr Professor
Cornella is working on on that cover
crops using him as a cover crop so that
is just coming up
well
um well thank you so much Dr Brenda
thank you so much for all of you uh to
attend and be interested in sticking
along uh for the last 30 minutes I
really appreciate it I was very
informative certainly there were a lot
of questions this time so that is that's
great
um so just next time in two weeks
actually on March 8th please join us for
our fourth seminar on outdoor
cultivation energy management by Dr
Heather Darby from University of Vermont
so I will see you all in two weeks
thank you so much
thank you very much and thank you Luis
for invited me to talk it's always a
pleasure
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu